ce vendredi marque la journée
internationale de lutte contre le cancer
et nous allons faire un focus sur les
nouvelles thérapies dites de précision
qui sont en train de créer un véritable
tournant d'immunothérapie en est une la
radio thérapie ciblée en est une autre
pour en parler à mes côtés julia siggers
bonjour je vous êtes notre spécialiste
ici des questions de santé on connaît
donc les thérapies traditionnelles comme
la chirurgie la radiothérapie pourquoi
il y à de nouveaux traitements donc vous
faites bien de le préciser on connaît
effectivement toutes ces thérapies dites
traditionnelles vous l'avais dit la
chirurgie la radiothérapie et la
chimiothérapie la chimiothérapie qui
sauvent de nombreuses vies il faut le
dire mais au prix de nombreux effets
secondaires pourquoi parce que ça rende
hommage les tissus sains qui sont autour
de la tumeur est aussi il ya un autre
problème c'est que on ne sait jamais si
finalement le patient a reçu la bonne
dose et surtout au bon endroit et c'est
pour cela qu'aujourd'hui les
scientifiques du monde entier se
tournent vers ce que l'on appelle les
thérapies ciblées contre le cancer ce
sont des médicaments intelligent si vous
voulez qu'ils arrivent à cibler en fait
les protéines qui sont responsables de
la multiplication des cellules
cancéreuses alors ici le tournant le
plus important scientifiques clairement
c'est la luminothérapie qui a gagné le
prix nobel de médecine en 2018 et pour
comprendre comment ça fonctionne aura il
faut comprendre en fait comment
fonctionne le système immunitaire l1 je
vais vous expliquer quand vous avez une
agression extérieure que ce soit de la
part d'une bactérie d'un virus ou d'un
allergène notre corps dispose d'un
arsenal de défense d'abord les barrières
naturelles comme la peau et les
muqueuses mais si le pathogène arrive à
rentrer dans le corps est bien là c'est
le système immunitaire qui va prendre le
relais et un petit peu comme un portique
de sécurité à l'aéroport par exemple
vous avez ces cellules t qu'on appelle
les les lymphocytes t qui vont venir
scanner les cibler les cellules pour
savoir si elles sont saines ou pas si
elles sont pas saines et bien elles
seront neutralisées et tout simplement
détruites et la question qu'on avait
pendant longtemps c'est pourquoi
finalement le système immunitaire est
incapables de repérer ces cellules
cancéreuses est il très récemment on a
découvert qu'elle avait en fait cette
capacité de développer un système de
camouflage et 2,2 d'apparaître en fait
enfin d'être complètement furtive par
rapport au système immunitaire elle
faisait sa grâce à une protéine que l'on
appelle pdl 1 et c'est ça qui a créé
l'idée de l'immunothérapie parce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut créer en
laboratoire des anticorps de synthèse
anticorps monoclonaux on peut les
modifier génétiquement et les aider
justement à aider le système immunitaire
à détecter ces cellules cancéreuses pour
pouvoir les détruire ça pourrait donc
changer la vie des patients ça c'est
important les essais cliniques ont
démontré des résultats positifs dans une
trentaine de cancer c'est énorme dont le
cancer du poumon du rhin et contre le
fameux mélanome malin absolument les les
effets seul et les résultats pour
l'instant des essais cliniques sont très
bons et c'est une technique est
d'ailleurs utilisé de plus en plus et
les effets secondaires sont aussi moins
important que pour la chimiothérapie le
seul risque que l'on peut avoir c'est
quand réinitialisant le système
immunitaire est bien celui ci peut
s'emballer et commencer à s'attaquer aux
cellules saines et là évidemment et bien
ça nous mène à adé à des maladies auto
immunes alors il ya une autre technique
de thérapie ciblée qui est très
intéressante aussi parce qu'elle cherche
aussi à réduire les effets indésirables
c'est la radio thérapie ciblée alors ici
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
injecter à l'intérieur d'une tumeur des
nanoparticules comme vous le voyez ici
et ce qui va en fait au final décupler
la force des rayons x quand on fera
justement cette radiothérapie mais que
au niveau de la tumeur et pas sur le
reste en fait c'était un peu le problème
de la radiothérapie c'est que les rayons
allez un petit peu partout sur le corps
et alors là une autre percée je pense
que vous allez être d'accord avec moi
zohra et c'est assez époustouflant des
scientifiques chinois et allemands ont
réussi à mettre au point un nanorobot ce
sont deux tout petits robots qui ont été
imprimés en 3d et qui cette fois ci vont
être véhiculées dans le sang dans les
veines vous allez le voir sur ces images
c'est absolument incroyable mais elle
ressemble en fait à des petits animaux
dont vous allez voir il ya un crabe ici
vous voyez ce crabe qui émaillent avant
de remonter en fait comme si c'était une
veine tout simplement pour aller au
point de la tumeur il va pouvoir par
exemple amené avec lui vous le voyez de
ce petit crabe robot qui va prendre la
particule médicamenteuse et qu'il va
pouvoir la mener d'un point a à un point
b et c'est comme ça qu'on va pouvoir
amener ces molécules jusqu'à la tumeur
on va pouvoir aussi créé des micros
thrombose haut niveau grâce à ces robots
au niveau de deux des cellules
cancéreuses pour que finalement et bien
le sang ne puisse plus atteindre ces
cellules et qu'elle meure d'elle même
alors évidemment tous ces thérapies
ciblées ne sont pas encore
disponible pour le grand public elle ne
fonctionne pas contre tous les cancers
mais en tout cas ça ouvre une nouvelle
voie une nouvelle aire thérapeutique
clairement construc ans à l'importance
donc de continuer les essais cliniques
merci beaucoup julia siggers porteuse de
bonnes nouvelles on peut le dire vous
êtes en cette journée internationale de
lutte contre le cancer mer